[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any of you
out there would like to ask
questions--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Good
morning, everyone.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz,
and I work for YouTube.
Here in the studio with me,
I have Jeremy Walker.
JEREMY WALKER: Hello.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How are
you doing, Jeremy?
JEREMY WALKER: I'm doing
pretty well today.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Good to see you.
Long time no see.
JEREMY WALKER: I know.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: On the
Hangout, we have Jeffrey
Posnick live from New York.
How's it going, Jeff?
JEFFREY POSNICK: I might
make it through the
show without coughing.
I think I'm at the tail end of
my illness, for those who have
been diligently following
along week to week.
So pretty good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Steady
progress, though.
That's iterative development.
JEFFREY POSNICK: It
definitely is.
I think I need maybe some agile
scrumming or something
like that to really get
me over the last bit.
I don't know.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
I think you need to improve
the bug fixing, Jeff.
JEFFREY POSNICK: That's
probably it.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
So we have an exciting
show for you today.
Jeremy has been quite
busy in his office.
And he agreed to disclose the
project that he has been
working on.
And I understand that it has
something to do with
application developers and
featuring applications.
So maybe we'll let Jeremy talk
some more about what he has
been doing.
JEREMY WALKER: Great, thanks.
So yeah, I've been working on a
new showcase for the YouTube
apps for all the ones that have
been submitted to us.
We basically had an older one
on the site right now.
It's been around awhile.
And we wanted to revamp it
to match the style of the
developers.google.com/showcase.
Well, showcase, just
match that one.
So what we started doing is
started getting together a
bunch of the great apps that
you guys have put out for
YouTube, and started getting
submissions.
And we hope to have the first
version up by early October,
so next week, actually.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So if I'm an
application developer, and I
would like my app to
be featured, what
do I need to do?
JEREMY WALKER: That's
a great question.
So go to our Google+ page
and just write us.
And we'll reach out to you,
and we'll get the process
kicked off.
But yeah, if you don't see
yourself on that list next
week, definitely reach out
to us and let us know.
Because we'd love to feature--
well, I mean, any of the work
you do with the YouTube APIs,
we always like to help
you guys out.
So definitely reach out to us.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: As far as the
mechanics of submissions
go, what does one need to have
ready in addition to a
beautiful, working,
innovative app?
JEREMY WALKER: That's
a great question.
So we actually need
a couple things.
We need a description of
300 characters or less.
That's very important.
Some people submitted
longer than that.
So if it's over 300, I'm going
to have to cut off,
unfortunately.
So make sure you get
it all into 300.
So that just tells us a little
bit about your app and how
you're integrated
with YouTube.
Screenshots and videos are good,
but most importantly are
the screenshots.
They have to be in 16 by
9 aspect ratio, so
make sure you do that.
Otherwise, I'm going
to cut them off to
make sure they fit.
And it may not match exactly
what you're looking for.
So just make sure
you get those.
We can have up to five.
Usually one would be used for
the thumbnail, and then just
five others that people
can scroll through.
And then those will be
added to the site.
Outside of that, you've
just got to tell me
the name of the company.
So it's really not
very much work.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
And then I understand that some
developers have already
submitted the information.
And there's some early
entries that we were
going to show today.
Is that right?
JEREMY WALKER: Yes, that's
exactly right.
So we had some people.
I sent out a list to the current
people that were
already part of the showcase and
people that we've already
worked with, and some of the
apps that we've already seen.
I sent out a huge mailing list
with the form to everyone.
And we did get some feedback.
So the people that did submit,
we're going to show some of
them today.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Let's go through some of them,
just to see what your thinking
process is like while accepting
or rejecting these
submissions.
So show us some of the
ones that you think
are worth being showcased.
JEREMY WALKER: OK.
So I'm going to share
my screen here.
Give me a moment.
All right.
So this is the first one.
This one's called VidCaster.
They're a pretty neat
little app.
Basically, what they do is they
help you create a video
portal very easily.
So let's say you have
a bunch of videos.
This happens to be my
YouTube channel.
I've got some Smart Squirrels
Gets Nuts, some old-time help
desk stuff.
Basically a bunch of stuff that
I uploaded to YouTube.
But I'm not that great at SEO,
let's say, and I don't want to
create a video player
from scratch.
And I'm not necessarily using
a white label player.
I just want to get a video
portal up with my content and
share it, but I don't want
to do a lot of the work.
So what they let you do-- and
this is their interface right
here-- is you basically import
your channel, which I've
already done here.
You select kind of a format
you want to use.
So in this case, I'm
just going to
use the basic rotator.
You add a logo, which I actually
already did here for
the YouTube.
And then you just confirm
your URL, and
you're pretty much done.
Outside of that, they help you
optimize a couple of things,
and they give you
tips and tricks.
There's a bit more to it, but
that gives you an idea.
This is a great use of YouTube
and very little work if you
already have your YouTube
videos up.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Congratulations, VidCaster.
If you guys are watching,
you'll be
a part of the showcase.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Anybody
else that you
would like to mention?
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, I got quite
a few more, actually.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right,
let's go for it.
JEREMY WALKER: So GoAnimate--
so you guys probably saw them.
We had them on a while back.
They're a great site.
So this is good if you're
kind of camera shy.
Some people maybe want
to make some
videos about their products.
And this is just a great
way to do it.
You don't need to get
a video camera.
You don't need to do
a whole production.
You just go to their
site, sign up.
And it's kind of a freemium
model, so you get a lot of
free stuff.
And if you want to add some more
of the cool stuff, then
you can pay for it.
But in this case, I'm going to
make a short video, an anime,
because I love anime
and manga.
So you just pick a couple
characters.
Well, first you pick a scene.
So you can see here, I'm
just going to pick
this Rice Cakes Home.
You just pick a couple
characters.
And then you just put
in some text.
So you can use these voices.
So I can say, "What's up?" And
then you can say, "YouTube
APIs are awesome." And
then I'm done.
And I hit Preview.
And you can see here it shows a
nice little preview of these
two people talking.
Give it a second to load.
And there they go.
You can't hear it.
"What's up?" And then it
shows a picture of
the cookies and tea.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Nice work.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
So you can see I did that
in like a minute.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then the
video that is created can be
uploaded to YouTube
and share it.
JEREMY WALKER: Exactly.
So you can upload this
to YouTube, and
then push it forward.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then for
those of you that would like
to learn more about how this
application came about, we
actually did host GoAnimate on
this show a little earlier.
So if you look through archival
coverage, actually,
then to view with them,
it's here in the show.
They were actually joining us
remotely from Hong Kong.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Anybody else
that you have on your list?
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah, I
got a couple more.
And then I might turn
it over to you.
So this one's called
Stupeflix.
This one is pretty cool.
So let's say I don't know
anything about editing video
together, or pictures, or
anything like that.
But I want to make
something cool.
I have all these cool pictures,
a couple of videos,
and some music.
But if I put it together, it's
going to look terrible,
honestly, because I'm not
a great design person.
So what this site lets you do
is basically you sign in.
You get one free credit.
And then you can get a plan.
But what you can do is you
can upload pictures.
Now here, I've already
uploaded.
I just had my son, and so I put
a couple pictures from him
from Picasa.
It lets you import from a lot
of sites, pretty much every
social site.
So you can import a
bunch of pictures.
You can even add audio-- upload
your own, or you can
just add some from their music
lounge, which is kind of what
they've already got.
And then you can add more,
like some more stuff.
But here, I can do
a quick preview.
And you can see it'll make a
cool little video based on the
theme I picked out.
So you didn't see the
theme page, but I
picked out a theme page.
And it'll do a nice
little video.
And I picked out the
most basic one.
So you're not going
to see much of it,
but you'll hear music.
And you can kind
of re-edit it.
And it makes a really nice video
that you can then export
to YouTube and share
with everyone.
So this is just a way to take
all your pictures and stuff
and put it together.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Nice.
JEREMY WALKER: And then I have
another one, Vidyard.
They make a white label player
for companies, but they are
also very deeply integrated
with YouTube.
So it's pretty nice.
On one side, you can have the
nice UI that you've set up for
your white label player.
But it also lets you actually
import the videos from your
YouTube account and also run
them with that same look and
feel with themes.
So in this case, I created
a little player.
And all these videos here--
Bad Morning, Smart Squirrel
Gets Nuts, and my webcam--
these are all from my channel.
And actually, I just
imported them.
And I chose a nice little
skin, and I play in it.
You can see it looks like your
own white label player.
Now, these guys offer a bunch of
extras, like analytics, and
AV testing, and all sorts of
good stuff for thumbnails.
But this is just a great white
label player that's integrated
deeply with YouTube that lets
you not only have your white
label player, but also your
YouTube, and kind of combines
them a little bit.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, I think
the interesting part
about Vidyard is they're similar
to some of the other
apps that we mentioned in that
it's a business offering.
So rather than consumer play,
when people create fun videos
and share with their friends,
actually they are very focused
on letting businesses really use
their video and leverage
the power of analytics to
measure things such as
conversion and how well the
video is actually going to
improve their bottom line.
So a very interesting
application.
Congrats, Vidyard, on
being featured.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes.
And then there's one that
I know I'm going to
let you talk about.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh,
right, Groovideo.
So we did host them previously
on our live show.
And for those of you that missed
it, what Groovideo
allows you to do is to actually
collaboratively
create video.
So the use case here
is you have
someone who has a birthday.
You send a bunch of invitations
to people that
would like to congratulate the
birthday girl or birthday boy.
And then they have the
ability to record
short snippets of videos.
Groovideo puts it all together
in a nice, entertaining video
and then presents it to the
person that the video was
created for.
So a very fun app.
I really encourage you
to check it out.
They have a mobile version of
the app, so you can actually
record the video with your
mobile device on the go.
And they really take care of
all the stitching together,
transcoding and uploading
to YouTube, so the
video can be shared.
Very interesting application.
Congrats to Groovideo.
There is a couple of more apps
that I'm very interested in
and I wanted to highlight.
One of that is Parrot.
And for those of you that
participated in Google I/O,
you might have seen them in
our Developer Sandbox.
Those of you that didn't, I have
a couple of videos that I
wanted to share.
One is a video that
I took in their
offices in Paris, France.
[WHIRRING NOISE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: This
is actually a drone.
Here's what it can do.
JEREMY WALKER: Oh, wow.
Did you actually do that flip?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I was filming
the flip, but a
colleague of mine was actually
operating a drone.
It's actually easier
than what it seems.
You can operate it
with a tablet.
They've done a really
nice job.
JEREMY WALKER: That's
pretty awesome.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then for
those of you that actually
came to Google I/O, you might
have seen the developer booth.
So this is a view of
Google I/O from the
perspective of the drone.
So actually, the drone is flying
over our Developer
Sandbox-- so here's YouTube,
a couple of
other Google products--
and taking video.
So what they have done is
allowed you to very easily
upload video from the
drone to YouTube.
So very, very interesting
application,
also a lot of fun.
And as you can see, it's
a pretty nice,
high-quality video.
So definitely a use case
that we like to see.
And here's the drone
filming itself.
All right.
We're on replay, so we can stop
this video and move on to
the next one.
JEREMY WALKER: All right.
And then I think the other thing
that was interesting,
too, is they actually integrated
with Google TV.
Because I remember in one of the
videos they presented of
our Sandbox, they showed
that integration.
So they were showing both
at the same time.
It was pretty cool.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, which
actually reminds me.
One of the features that we
have on the showcase, on
developers.google.com, is we can
actually tag the product
with multiple APIs that
are being used.
So if you are building an app,
and you use a bunch of
different APIs.
Like in the case of Parrot's
YouTube API, Google TV, then
mention that, because that
will help your app to be
discovered.
If someone's looking for
examples of specific
integrations, they
can actually see
you up right there.
So is that extra points?
JEREMY WALKER: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
Let's look at a couple of other
applications that I
wanted to share with you.
These ones are actually mobile
apps, so I'm going to switch
over to my tablet here.
And I'll show you a
couple of them.
So let's take a look
at the first one.
And this is Band of the
Day by 955 Dreams.
For those of you that came to
Google I/O, you might have
caught our joint presentation
about building mobile
applications for content
creators and consumers.
So Kiran, the CEO of 955 Dreams,
was actually speaking.
And here is their app.
So what this app allows you to
do is basically, every day,
get a new band that
you can discover.
So let's just check out today's
band, Freddie Gibbs.
You can actually learn more
about the artist, read the
bio, read reviews,
and so forth.
And obviously, you can
also watch videos.
So they integrated the YouTube
embed player on iOS, so this
is running inside
of the UIWebView
using the iFrame embed.
So if you hit Play, it'll
actually play the video in the
application.
Now, another application
that we also have in
the gallery is Flipboard.
Flipboard, for those of you that
are not familiar with it,
it's a social magazine.
So you can actually integrate a
lot of various data sources.
They also have their own
recommendations and curation
capability.
And then you can consume it all
within a simple, beautiful
experience.
Recently, Flipboard integrated
YouTube API, so this is my
Flipboard feed.
I have tiles representing
various data sources.
And then if I scroll
to the last page, I
have my YouTube videos.
So, you can actually see
my subscriptions.
I'm a big fan of PBS NewsHour.
This is where I get my news.
I have to admit, I'm a big
Epic Meal Time fan.
And this is where I get
cooking recipes from.
If you guys haven't seen them,
it's actually quite fun.
So between coding sessions, it's
a great way to relax and
catch up on the latest cuisine
recommendations.
And a couple of others.
So really, what you see here
is the subscriptions are
actually fetched using the
YouTube API and presented
inside of the Flipboard app.
And you can also interact with
the content, so you can like a
video directly from the app.
You can comment on the
video as well.
So as you see here, I can write
a comment directly from
the application.
And the way this is implemented
is by using the
YouTube API.
JEREMY WALKER: They have a
couple API integrations, too,
didn't they?
They launched a week
before I/O?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
I think they also integrated
G+ as a
part of the same release.
So yeah, definitely an
interesting integration example.
So I think this is all
we have for today.
But I understand that the
list is actually larger.
JEREMY WALKER: Yes, yes.
It is much larger.
So we're launching with
about 35, so check
that out next week.
We've been talking
with most of you
anyway about this stuff.
So if you also would like to
come talk to us on the show,
we're very interested
in that, too.
So continue reaching
out to us.
And again, if you're not on
that first list, then
definitely reach out to us
on our Google+ page.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Don't despair,
and just reach out.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
We'll get you up as soon as you
get us the information.
Well, not as soon, but probably
a week later or so.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Sounds good.
And I think also looking through
the gallery will give
you a good idea about the types
of applications that we
feel are interesting and worth
spreading the word about from
our perspective.
So let this be the guide as
well, if you would like to
participate in the showcase.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
That's on
developers.google.com/showcase.
Just remember "showcase."
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So now we have some
time left over.
So I know another thing you have
been recently working on
is some blogging, Jeremy.
How's that going?
JEREMY WALKER: Good, good.
I actually did my first blog
post on the YouTube API.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Congratulations.
JEREMY WALKER: Thanks.
I thought it was important to
talk about YouTube channels
and business, so I wanted
to do that first.
So I don't know if any
of you guys saw it.
If you went to I/O, or you've
been watching I/O videos, then
you've probably seen the
presentation by Dror and AJ.
They're two of our PMs and
experts in channels.
They did this great presentation
on why it's
important to have a channel
on YouTube.
Not only do we have 800 million
unique users per
month, but people don't realize
how easy it is to have
a presence.
And you notice I said
"presence." I didn't say
"create video." I said
"presence." So you can create
video, and it's very easy,
and they go into that.
But a lot of channels actually
curate content from their
users that use their apps
or products or whatever.
So they go into that, too.
So there's really a
lot of options.
So they basically broke it down
to three basic categories
around what your goal is.
The first one is raising
awareness.
The second one is raising money,
so any of you startups
out there, if you want
to look into that,
that's pretty important.
They go into some studies on
like how much it increases to
have video--
how much more money you get.
So it's pretty important
to check that out.
Again, Kickstarter, Indiegogo,
stuff like that.
So check that out.
And then finally, research and
supporting your users.
So you can kind of figure
out-- it's a great R&D
environment, YouTube is.
You can figure out
what features are
popular, what are not.
And you can get a lot of
analytics around that to make
your decisions.
So maybe you build
this out more.
You may be surprised that people
really like a feature
that you didn't think
much about.
So they kind of go into little
studies about each of those.
And the really neat thing about
the presentation is
every slide or so, they
show a video.
And they're funny videos.
They're good videos, because
they're content.
They're not commercials, which
they'll drive home a lot.
But basically, it's really
a joy to watch it.
It's like watching a playlist
with commentary in between.
So I did a short blog
post on it.
That's up now, so
check that out.
I embedded the video there.
So I'd strongly suggest you
check it out, especially if
you're building something out,
whatever you're doing.
If you're building an app, and
you want some exposure,
definitely follow that.
And then they give you some
great resources after that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Yeah, I saw the presentation.
And we actually hosted Dror and
AJ before Google I/O to
speak about the presentation.
So very useful.
As you said, whether you're a
content creator or you're an
entrepreneur, and you would like
to use YouTube to really
promote your product, whether
you create the content
yourself or you let
crowd-sourced content serve as
the promotional videos for
your product, you can
definitely do that.
Jeff will probably like me to
say that YouTube Direct is a
great way to actually achieve
that, solicit
the videos from users.
In fact, a lot of businesses are
doing it that way, so they
don't actually have to hire
someone to produce the videos
because the users
do it for them.
And sometimes they actually are
very fun and innovative
videos that they can get.
So a great, fun session.
I think one thing that you
didn't mention is there's a
lot of cool videos in
the video itself.
So really fun and
entertaining.
I highly recommend that
you check it out.
Great.
So I know Jeff has been busy
with our Stack Overflow
transition.
Jeff, how is that going?
Any update from your front?
JEFFREY POSNICK: For those who
have not been following along
with our communication, we've
announced in a couple places
now for a while that we're going
to be getting rid of--
or I guess turning into
read-only mode--
our existing Google group that
we previously used for support
with any questions about the
YouTube Data or Player APIs.
And instead, we're encouraging
folks to do one of two things
if they need any help
with the APIs.
Either if it's a feature request
or if it's reporting a
bug, opening an issue in our
Issue Tracker hosted on
code.google.com is the best
way of doing that.
And that'll just make sure
it gets our attention.
We could assign internal bug
IDs to these things.
It's actually a lot better than
the old situation where
people would post about a
bug to a mailing list.
And then we'd have to track down
the original posting to
update people, and lots of
duplication, things like that.
So Issue Tracker for
certain things.
And then for just general
YouTube API questions, like,
how do I do this?
Is it possible to do that?
We're asking that folks
use Stack Overflow.
And that's something that people
had been doing just
kind of organically anyway,
without any
encouragement on our part.
Stack Overflow is a great
resource that developers just
know about and know
to go to use.
And the nice thing is that
now, we're going to be
actually officially providing
support from our
team on Stack Overflow.
So in addition to getting
questions answered by members
of just the general Stack
Overflow community, you'll get
me answering some questions and
Jarek and Jeremy answering
some questions as well.
So yeah, I've enjoyed it.
It's been nice watching my Stack
Overflow reputation grow
as I started posting.
As a consumer of Stack Overflow
answers, I guess,
they always tend to be great
answers that show up in search
results when you're trying
to solve something.
I spent all my time posting
in Google group.
I couldn't also devote the
time to Stack Overflow.
So now I'm building up my Stack
Overflow reputation and
enjoying that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, Jeff.
And thanks for actually dressing
up our section there
on Stack Overflow with a nice
logo and everything.
I think that makes
it more official.
I think we are now legit.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yes, we are.
And October 15 is the date
that we're going to be
switching the old discussion
Google group
into read-only mode.
But don't wait until then to
start either using the Issue
Tracker or start of
Stack Overflow.
I definitely encourage you
to do one of those.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
We have some time left, so why
don't we check the question
section on our moderator.
So we have two questions here.
One is from Jeremy Walker.
I know this person.
It's about hiring.
Is Google YouTube Developer
Relations hiring?
JEREMY WALKER: Yes, we are.
Google Developer Relations is
hiring, and so is YouTube.
So apply.
We're very interested.
Just go to the site and look
at the jobs listings, and
apply, apply, apply.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
Next one is from Jeffrey
Posnick, also a
very familiar name.
New York City.
So the question is about
playback of YouTube videos on
iOS 6, whether there have been
any changes in this area.
JEFFREY POSNICK: Yes.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I'll
let you answer your
own question, Jeff.
This is, by the way, Stack
Overflow style.
JEFFREY POSNICK: This is
the only way I could
get anybody's attention.
I feel like I need to use
the built-in moderator.
But no, I've been seeing a lot
of questions about recently.
And I don't have the full
answer, but I wanted to just
share what I think has
changed so far.
I actually haven't had a chance
to update some of the
test devices I have
to iOS 6 yet.
But just a little bit
of background.
For folks who have previously
embedded YouTube videos on web
pages and had those either play
back in the mobile Safari
on an iOS device or within a UI
WebKit view within an iOS
application, if you've
used the embed tag--
like brackets embed,
basically--
and used that to embed a video,
playback was previously
handled by the, I guess, now the
legacy YouTube application
that was installed
on the phone.
It would actually open up the
YouTube application, play back
the video, and then go back to
your web page or application
when that was done.
That's changed in iOS 6.
And what I think has been
happening based on what I've
been hearing from folks is
that the tags are being
automatically translated
into iFrame embed tags.
And then playback is happening
inline now, which is what you
normally see with an
iFrame player.
And it's using native HTML5
video within those apps.
So that's not something
we have complete
control over, actually.
So if you're seeing this, it
caught me a little bit by
surprise, although it
does make sense.
But I think that's what
you're seeing.
I don't know whether, Jarek or
Jeremy, you've had a chance to
play around at all and confirm
any of that, or what.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
I think on the
iPad is inline playback.
I believe on iPhone devices,
it's still full screen.
I think the difference is, as
you mentioned, it's actually
using the HTML5 video tag.
So the old legacy embeds will
still continue working.
They're just being rewritten
as the iFrame embeds.
So now, our iFrame embed
implementation is going to
kick in, although that
internally uses the video tag
implementation provided
by the browser on
these mobile devices.
So if you see any issues
or any feedback,
please let us know.
Ping us on G+ or ask a
question here in the moderator.
If you have problems
embedding--
JEFFREY POSNICK: Don't
ping us on Google+.
Ask a Stack Overflow question
or open a bug
in the Issue Tracker.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, sure.
See, I'm still getting used to
the new world, apparently.
But listen to Jeff.
Definitely that's the
right process.
All right.
So I think this is it.
No more questions, so I think
this is a short and sweet
session today.
I would like to thank Jeremy
for spending all the time
putting together the showcase.
I understand it's launching
early next quarter, so I'm
looking forward to that.
And then again, if you have an
application you would like
featured, please let us know.
And check out the ones that
we'll be launching just to get
a basic idea about what type of
quality we're looking for.
In the meantime, keep
innovating, keep hacking, and
I guess we'll see you
again next week.
We'll be looking into
a live from New York
session next week.
I'm just confirming a very
exciting guest, so it should
be pretty fun.
And Jeff, thank you very much.
I think you're making
steady progress.
I've been counting your coughs,
and definitely the
trend is the right one.
They are decreasing right in
time for the flu season
starting on the East Coast.
All right, thank
you very much.
JEFFREY POSNICK:
Bye, everybody.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Until
the next week, bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]